GREG DEMICHILLIE: Our second
speaker on our second topic
is about security.
Niels Provos is a
distinguished engineer
at Google focused on
security and privacy.
Now for context, there
are only about 50
distinguished engineers
inside all of Google.
Now, and according to
his Wikipedia page,
in his spare time he's
turned steel into swords.
You know, and
security is different
than many other features.
It's an opportunity
for us to work with you
to create the best possible
security environment for you,
your customers.
And with GCP, we have
a great opportunity
to put more and
more of the tools
that we use to manage our
security into your hands,
so that you can manage
your security as well.
So with that I'm
really delighted
and honored to bring up
on stage Niels Provos,
distinguished
engineer from Google.
Neil.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NIELS PROVOS: Thank you
for the introduction, Greg.
Good morning, everybody.
As Greg said, I am a
distinguished engineer
at Google.
I am responsible for
the security and privacy
engineering teams.
Today, I would like to pull
back the covers a little bit
and share with you a glimpse
on how we pervasively
secure you, your
data, your customer's
data, and your applications
when you run on top
of Google's cloud platform.
However, let me set the
stage a little bit first.
At the recent Enigma conference
in San Francisco, Rob Joyce,
the head of NSA's
Tailored Access Operations
made the following
statements on how
advanced adversaries managed
to break into your systems
and networks.
Now I understand
that most of you
would like to spend
your time and focus
on building a great product
and great new features
for your customers.
However, your adversaries, they
focus their time and energy
on finding weak spots in your
systems that they can exploit.
Fortunately, at
Google I lead the team
of experts, who build systems
and processes, specifically
designed to thwart adversaries.
We do this by anticipating
them, preventing them,
detecting them, disrupting
them, and containing them.
And we will work with
you to make sure that we
can meet your requirements.
And that you can leverage
our security capabilities
on top of the platform.
So now I would like to give
you a little bit more insight
into how we think about
security at Google,
and how we have created a secure
infrastructure for ourselves.
Google security and
privacy team consists
of over 500 people,
who continuously
work to protect
our infrastructure,
and you when you're
running on top of GCP.
Due to our scale,
we end up seeing
all kinds of bad behavior
across the internet-- phishing
emails, malware websites,
network attacks.
And we also see all
kinds of adversaries,
ranging from all levels
of sophistication.
Not just script kiddies and
cybercriminals, but also
nation state actors.
Now at Google, we are
not pursuing a hard shell
or perimeter model.
Instead we are really focused
on pervasive defense and death.
This is similar to the
immune system analogy
that Urs mentioned yesterday.
There are two key principles
running pervasively
to our approach to
security, and they
are trust and transparency.
That means that we design for
trust throughout our stack.
And we build in
the transparency,
so that you can
verify for yourself.
And in fact, this talk is
one of our steps in giving
you more transparency.
Now I'll be talking about
Google's infrastructure.
In the first part
of the talk-- how
we think about security there.
And then the second
part of the talk, I
will explain how that applies to
you when you run on top of GCP.
In order to facilitate
this discussion,
we have split our stack
into eight different layers.
And I'll be walking
from the bottom
up, starting with the
hardware, to the boot process,
all the way up to deployment,
operations, and usage.
At the hardware layer,
we are fortunate enough
that we operate at
such a skill that we
can build our own
proprietary secure systems.
That means that we have
purpose-built hardware
for computing, storage
networking, all the way
through the full data
centers, as you just
heard Joe talk about.
Our ability to design and
deploy custom hardware
means that we can maintain
provenance and establish trust
at the hardware level.
Now on top of this
trusted hardware,
it's important that we can
also boot in a trusted way.
And to accomplish that, we
have complied code signing that
allows us to verify the BIOS,
the bootloader, and the kernel.
And that means that only
the intended software can
run on Google's infrastructure.
So now that we know that
our machines have booted
in the known good state,
it's also important
that all of our jobs communicate
in an authenticated and
authorized fashion.
To accomplish
that, we have built
a cryptographic key
distribution system
called LoA, that
allows us to establish
cryptographic identities
for all jobs that
run on our infrastructure.
We know and audit the
binaries that run,
so we can establish trust, not
only at the operating system,
but also for the apps
that are running on it.
Now we have heard a lot
about virtual machines.
And one of the properties
we really need there
is secure isolation.
At Google, we use KVM as
our hypervisor technology,
and we have
significantly invested
to harden its security.
That means that
our security teams
have found 15 of the last 21
publicly known vulnerabilities
in KVM.
That means that we are the first
to fix, and the first to patch.
But of course, we also
contribute our findings
back to the community
so that everybody
can benefit from a more
secure KVM technology.
And we continue on working
to make KVM even more secure.
To get a secure operating
system image in our machines,
we have created a
Google curated image
that we run throughout our
production infrastructure.
This is very similar to the
recommendation from the NSA
of having a secure baseline.
We have also deployed
a service that
alerts us of vulnerabilities
and third-party source code
to further protect our services.
Now, at the storage layer,
it's really important
that all access to
data is individually
authorized and echoed.
Before we write data to disk,
we chunk it and spread it,
so that not all data ends
up on the same server.
We also encrypt data and
metadata individually.
And to protect these
encryption keys,
we have built a system called
keystore, that wraps them
by encrypting them further.
Our storage systems only
store this rep key, never
the original cryptographic
key that would be
required to decrypt the data.
And that means that
all access to data
requires interaction
with keystore,
which gives us logging
and auditing capabilities.
Similar for data and
motion, we encrypt it
when it travels between
systems that we control.
We accomplish
fine-grained control
over access with our
internal IEM systems,
and they also give us logging
and other capabilities.
So now at this point, we are
running on trusted hardware.
We know that the boot
process was trusted
and we trust our
operating system.
And we also have provenance
for hardware, boot, and OS.
We encrypt the data, or
we know that all access
is authentic and authorized.
Now to secure our
applications, we
are pursuing multiple
layered approaches.
One of them is that we have
built a binary on configuration
verification system.
That means that for
all applications,
we know how they were built, we
know how they were configured,
and we know how
they were deployed.
And for each of
these steps, we know
who was responsible for them.
To put additional security
into our development process
we require that all
code gets peer reviewed.
That means there's a second pair
of eyes that looks at the code
before it's being
committed, so that we
can find bugs and security
problems very early on.
To help our teams create
more secure systems,
we also require security of
you before anything can launch.
That means that we can put
security into our products
right at the design phase.
However, even with
the best practices,
you still cannot prevent
all security problems.
And so we have created a
security scanning technology
that allows us to find many
of the common mistakes--
cross-site scripting, mixed
content, mixed pinning.
You know, more strange
attacks such as Rosetta Flash.
And we have also used
this as an example,
and where we can contribute
back to the community,
we have made our Firing
Range testbed open-source.
That is, if anybody
else would like
to develop their own security
technology-- scanning
technology, we already
have a ready-made app
that they can test against.
So at this point, our
applications are reviewed,
they have been
tested, we believe
they don't have vulnerabilities,
data is encrypted,
and access is authorized.
But now, it's time to
expose these applications
to the dangerous web.
And there are multiple
different ways
in which we secure our
applications there.
First of all, on the network we
protect the traffic with TLS.
To prevent
man-in-the-middle attacks,
we have put certificate pinning
into our Chrome browser,
so that we only trust
the right certificates.
We have also deployed
unphishable user identity
to our users with unphishable
hardware second factors.
And to protect against
network attacks,
we have built in
DDoS protection.
Some of you might
have heard recently
about Project Shield, where we
announce that we're extending
this DDoS protection to news and
human rights organizations, as
well as election
monitoring sites.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
At the operations level,
we have built technology
that allows us to
patch and monitor,
to incident response, forensics,
threat analysis, and threat
intelligence.
And this is also
another example,
where we have contributed
back to the open-source
for making some of our
forensic tools available,
such as GRR or recall
for memory analytics.
Now, one of the sayings
that we have is,
the first user who is going
to be hitting your application
is likely going
to be an app user.
So we give our
developers the tools
to be able to do reputation
checks on URLs and binaries.
We have automated
analysis of traffic
to find botnets that
might be engaging in spam.
And we also leverage our
global view on botnets
to build threat intelligence on
bad actors and current attack
vectors.
However, to reduce the overall
attack surface that we face,
and that our users face on the
internet, and that all of you
face, we created
Project Zero in 2014.
It's a team dedicated to
finding zero-day vulnerabilities
in critical internet software.
You may have heard about the
Heartbleed bug in open SSL,
Urs mentioned that
briefly yesterday.
Or about rowhammer, where
just reading memory can
lead to remote code execution.
And most recently we announced
a widespread security
vulnerability in GDIPC.
So that means that
we have a team that
finds critical security problems
that are very widely spread.
And we get the benefit of
knowing about these first,
so we can fix our
infrastructure,
but we can also work with
the rest of the community
to make sure that we get
the infrastructure fixed
in general.
As I mentioned in
the previous slide,
writing secure
software is difficult.
And Google has been one
of the first companies
to create a vulnerability
rewards program,
where we asked researchers
across the world with helping
find security bugs
on our products.
And just last year, we
paid out over $2 million
to hundreds of
researchers, who helped
us build more secure products.
So now, let's
switch over to GCP.
I have just told you, and I hope
you understand a little better
about the security
capabilities that we
have built for ourselves.
You might wonder-- that's great,
but how does that apply to us,
and when we run on GCP.
These security capabilities
that I mentioned to you,
is what enables our
Google Developers
to live the V3 cloud
experience-- the next cloud
experience.
It means that they can focus
on building amazing products,
and they do not have
to be security experts.
Now we understand
that many of you
are on a spectrum on how
you develop and manage
your applications.
And all of you are going
to be in different points
in your journey to this
next version of cloud.
We understand that you may
have to manage and segment
your network to
create trust zones.
Or that you need more
explicit control over the file
or of the network perimeter.
All of you need logging
and auditing capabilities.
And we're really committed
to help you meet your goals,
wherever you are on your
journey to this next version
of the cloud.
And to accomplish that,
we are increasingly
making more of these
capabilities available to you.
And I'll be explaining
to you a little bit,
how that is going to look like.
So I mentioned previously,
we had eight layers,
in recognition of the
need that many of you
need better control
over the network.
We have introduced the
network layer here.
So I mentioned to you
what it is that we
do at the hardware
level, what it
is that we do for
our boot process,
and at the operating
system level.
You are actually benefiting
off all of these mechanisms
already, because GCP is
built on top of this.
Many of you have ultra
compliance requirements
and our infrastructure
is regularly
audited by external
auditors for SOC 2 and 3,
ISO 27001, PCI DSS 3.0, and
for Google Compute Engine,
Google Cloud Storage,
Cloud SQL, and BigQuery,
we are also covered
under the HIPAA BAA.
That means that you can build
on top of an infrastructure
foundation that is regularly
audited and certified.
For cloud, at the
storage level, all data
is already encrypted
by default. To give you
even greater control on how
data is being stored at rest,
we have made customer
supplied encryption keys
available to you.
And we also give you audit
logging capabilities.
In the future, we plan on
giving you even more control
with a key management
system, that
allows you to manage your
own keys-- generate them,
rotate them, suspend, resume
them, delete them, or manage
the import and
export of secrets.
Yesterday, you have heard
about our IM system,
that we have not made
available to you,
which gives you explicit
role-based access control.
And we will give you
additional capabilities
later on in the year.
Now at the network
layer, many of you
require explicit control.
In fact, today there
are already many ways
in which you can
customize your network,
such as with isolated IP groups,
private IP addresses, VPNs,
or inbound firewalls.
We are working on
extending and expanding
these features, including
outbound firewalls.
When you run on
Google App Engine,
you already can benefit from the
security of scanning technology
that I mentioned to you earlier.
But with the cloud
security scanner,
we are working on
creating more scanners.
And on increasing the
scanning capabilities,
so it can also use
it on GCE and GKE.
We also plan to give you the
ability to sign your binaries,
so you can verify
and enforce what
gets to run as part of
your infrastructure.
We are also thinking of giving
you source code security
capabilities.
However, that requires
that you first
store your source code with us.
So please check out the Google
Cloud source repositories.
For protecting your
developers and users,
we already give you
the options of using
security keys, which give
you this unphishable hardware
second factor.
Many of you at
the moment, may be
relying on this sort of
hard network parameter
that I've been
talking about earlier.
We also plan on giving you
detailed and sophisticated
identity and
authorization tools.
That means that you can
write access policy, not just
based on the user, but also
on the machine and location.
You may have heard about
the BeyondCorp model
yesterday, that sort of
goes in that direction.
When you leverage
Google's scale,
by using let's say the
HTTPS load balancer,
you also benefit from
built-in DDoS protection.
To protect your SSL
and TLS certificates,
we have been working for years
on something that is called
certificate transparency.
That essentially
creates publicly
verifiable logs, that give
you provenance and trust
for the certificates
for your own domains.
For operations, you already
benefit, essentially
from all the
practices that we have
for the underlying
infrastructure--
will be regularly
patch and upgrade.
However, for your
own projects, we
are looking into giving you an
integrated view that gives you
an idea of the patch
level of vulnerabilities
for your own deployments.
And we are also thinking of ways
of adding some of our threat
intelligence into that for you.
You already can benefit
from all that logging
and stack driver to
give you a better idea
and detailed records
of what's going
on with your infrastructure
and your data.
In the future, we plan on
giving a strong authors,
hardware second factor for
logging into your projects.
But we are also investigating
additional app use signals
that we might be able
to make available to you
when you develop your
application, such as URL
and binary reputation.
So these are just some of
the security capabilities
that we will increasingly
make available to you
to access and control.
You already have
the option for us
to manage the security
on the platform
if you use, for example
Google App Engine.
But we also plan on
giving you the ability
to leverage an increasing
array of security features
that you can manage to
your own requirements.
And to be clear,
our goal here is
to provide you the
control you need
on the trusted and
transparent cloud.
So that you do not have to
become security experts.
But can instead
focus on innovation
and creating a great business.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]